let's do a few examples adding rational
expressions so let's say we had
negative
x squared
over
x squared minus seven x
plus six
and to to that i want to add i want to
add plus x
minus
4. so to some degree what i want to do
in this
first example is kind of our algebraic
long division or polynomial division in
reverse i want to put this x minus 4 in
the numerator with x squared minus 7x
plus 6 in the denominator and the
easiest way to do that is to just
literally multiply
x minus 4 times
x squared minus seven x plus six
over
over
x squared minus seven x plus six i'm not
changing the number i'm multiplying it
by
1. so if we do that what do we get what
do we get well we just have to multiply
this numerator right here and we can do
that with algebraic multiplication so if
we have
x squared
x squared
minus seven x
plus six
times
x minus four
we can multiply these two six times
negative four is negative twenty four
negative four times negative 7x is
positive 28x negative 4 times x squared
is negative 4
x squared and if x times 6 is 6x x times
negative 7x is negative seven x squared
x times x squared is x to the third
so the new numerator is going to be x to
the third
minus this is 11
x squared
plus 34x
minus 24. so now i can rewrite this
let me copy and paste this this
let me copy and then paste it
it's going to be equal to that
plus
plus
i can rewrite this thing now
as being over a denominator
of x squared minus seven x
plus six and our numerator x minus 4
times this thing over here we get this
whole thing we multiplied them out x to
the third
minus 11 x squared plus 34 x
minus
24
and now since we have the exact same
denominator we can add these two
rational expressions so if you add them
you literally can just say well we have
the common denominator so our common
denominator is
is x squared minus seven x plus six that
was the whole point of multiplying the
this thing by the this expression over
this expression so that we could get the
common denominator and i would just add
the numerator so this is going to add to
the x squared side so you're still going
to have an x to the third
x to the third and then negative or
minus 11 x squared minus another x
squared is minus 12 x squared plus 34
x
minus 24
and we are
done now we could have checked whether
we could have factored this but this
just factors into
x minus 6 times x minus 1. so it really
doesn't factor with the x minus 4 in any
meaningful way so there really isn't any
further simplification that we can do
for this problem hopefully you enjoyed
that